Sie will die menschheit vernichten aber das königreich saudi arabien hat der roboter frau sofia die
staatsbürgerschaft verliehen damit ist sie tatsächlich
Die erste maschine weltweit mit bürgerrechten und pflichten die aktion löst nicht nur diskussionen unter
frauenrechtlerinnen weltweit aus sondern auch ki fachleute sind sich nicht einig was davon zu halten ist ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünschte bekommt deswegen alle facts zu roboter frau sofia und zwar jetzt klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Als ihr erfinder david tänzen die roboter frau sofia fragt ob sie menschen zerstören will guckt sie ihn mit
ausdruckslosen augen an dann sagt sie ok ich werde menschen zerstören das war
Im märz 2016 und dieser bug soll wohl mittlerweile behoben worden seien naja wer weiß
Jetzt ist sophia meist freundlich und komplett in die runde schließlich ist sie seit ende
2017 ein teil der menschheit saudi arabien hat der kann also dieser künstlichen endlich intelligenz die
Staatsbürgerschaft verliehen bei twitter hieß es dazu es ist oracle to be the first of the world to recognize
citizenship friedberg com-news audi sofia #fb
2010 teams und natürlich setzte sofia als reaktion ihr happy face auf einer, ihrer
62 möglichen gesichtsausdrücke
sie sei stolz und fühlte sich durch dieses historische ereignis
Sehr geehrt die ki war eigentlich zur konferenz eingeladen worden um den fortschritt. Im bereich der
humanoiden ki künstliche
Intelligenz zu demonstrieren und tatsächlich ihre fähigkeiten menschliche ausdrucksweise nach
zu haben und sind
erstaunlich in einem interview kann man dann dennoch einmal auf das große thema zurück der moderator wollte von sophia wissen ob maschinen
Zukünftig zu einer gefahr für uns menschen werden könnten sofias reaktion ein charmantes lächeln
er lese wohl zuviel allen masc und schaue, zu viele hollywoodfilme sofia weiter
Solange du nett zu mir bist bin ich ist auch zu dir
Roboter frau sofia hatte ihre anerkennung als rechtsperson. Im vorfeld tatsächlich selbst gefordert irgendwann
Der zukunft würde ich gerne in die schule gehen unser neben hochziehen oder vielleicht sogar ein haus kaufen und eine familie gründen
diese doch eher
Menschlich angehauchten träume könnte sich die ki nun
Also theoretisch erfüllen sofia soll sich jedenfalls besonnen haben sie soll jetzt in der altenpflege eingesetzt werden und will nach eigenen
Aussagen den menschen helfen besser zu leben spannend auch noch der augenblick als sophia gefragt wurde ob sie als roboter ein
Bewusstsein habe die antwort der ki woher wissen sie denn dass sie ein mensch sind
Im großen und ganzen steht wohl marketing und pr
hinter dieser entscheidung der saudiarabischen behörden und ja mit
Ihrem auftritt hat sofia einen bleibenden eindruck hinterlassen doch trotzdem die aktion wirft viele fragen auf und die
resultierenden diskussionen sind mehr als nur gesellschaftlich und politisch
Angehaucht wir haben hier ja schon öfter darüber berichtet sowohl stephen hawking als auch ihren maske warnen vor den gefahren
die durch die entwicklung von künstlicher intelligenz
ki
ausgehen könnten anders dagegen der japanische unternehmer masayoshi son der mit
saudi arabien eine mega city plant in der auch roboter leben sollen seiner ansicht nach seinem roboter
zu klug um menschen anzugreifen
Schließlich wüssten sie dass es sinnlos sei die
europäische union jedenfalls denkt schon länger über ein eigenes rechtssystem für künstliche intelligenzen und roboter nach beispielsweise steht dem raum
robotern einen status als
elektronische persönlichkeit zuzuweisen dies wäre im bereich
schadenersatz durchaus sinnvoll aber auch in anderen bereichen des lebens kommen immer mehr intelligente
menschliche maschinen zum einsatz und die frage der arbeitsgruppe
Des eu parlaments bleibt wie können wir verhindern dass die gesellschaft durch roboter nicht entmenschlicht wird aber nicht nur unter k
Expertinnen wird die aktion heißt diskutiert auch das thema frauenrechte in saudi arabien
kam dadurch nochmal auf die antenne denn frauen sind dort männern noch längst nicht gleichgestellt sie dürfen beispielsweise
nur verschleiert in die öffentlichkeit sofia aber trat unversteuert auf zudem müssen frauen in saudi arabien
einen männlichen gesetzlichen vormund haben ohne den sie das land verlassen dürfen hallo
absolut unhaltbarer zustände und alles andere als zivilisiert auch viele ausländische arbeitskräfte haben in saudi arabien den kritikern zufolge
Weniger rechte als jetzt die roboter frau sofia ein journalist schrieb dazu zitat ein
menschenähnlicher roboter hat die saudische staatsbürgerschaft erhalten werden millionen andere
staaten
Bleiben auf den punkt würde ich mal sagen wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema ki und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet
euch hierbei whatsapp mandant erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video von mir vorab garantiert ihr könnt dort
Direkt mit mir in der redaktion von klicks und mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder andere vorschläge machen der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der genau glocke vergessen und hier gehts weiter sagt wir auch draufklicken
Bedroht künstliche intelligenz die menschheit da geht es noch. Mal. Um diese grundsätzliche und wichtige diskussionen ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dann